hi I'm Megan from Khan Academy and I'm
here to share more about the content
available on Khan Academy when we talk
about content on Khan Academy what we
really mean is all the videos articles
and practice questions that learners
interact with we think about all of
those as split into two categories
the videos and articles are
instructional content and the practice
questions are practice content taken
together our goal is to provide learners
with the ability to learn about anything
they might encounter in a K through 12
classroom and then practice what they've
learned a key part of that practice is
that they'll get instant feedback about
how they're doing along with work
solutions to help them get back on track
if they're not quite clear on a
particular concept in this video we'll
explain the content we offer for
teachers and students and what makes it
special we know many people are familiar
with Khan Academy's great math content
but people are often unaware that Khan
Academy has more than math people might
be surprised to learn that we've
recently launched a beta version of our
new English Language Arts content our
goal is to eventually cover all core
academic subjects K through 14 we aren't
there yet but if you haven't explored
beyond math there are dozens of other
courses in the sciences finance and
economics and arts and humanities we
also have test prep content including
free official SAT practice created in
partnership with College Board an
official practices core prep developed
in collaboration with ETS
we absolutely have not forgotten about
math though we recently published a
series of get ready for grade level math
courses for third grade to precalculus
the best prepare students for on grade
level courses if you are looking to
learn something new you can view all of
our courses by clicking the drop-down
menu in the top left of the Khan Academy
website you can also find content to
support learning a new skill by using
our search function to search by skill
name or by Common Core State standard
Khan Academy's content is organized into
courses most of our courses are divided
into units and within every unit are
multiple lessons lessons include
instructional and practice resources
such as videos articles and exercises in
many courses quizzes combined practice
from several preceding lessons units end
with a test that checks understanding of
the entire unit Khan Academy has a lot
of content created by a team of former
teachers and subject matter experts our
team ensures that all of this content is
high-quality by partnering with leading
educational organizations and external
experts to make sure our content is up
to date and genuinely aligned to
standards for math in collaboration with
external reviewers we also tag all
content with regards to rigor to be sure
we are appropriately balancing
conceptual procedural and application
content as teachers we know you have
many options when it comes to using
tools in your classroom so you might be
asking yourself what makes Khan
Academy's content unique well Khan
Academy's content is interactive we have
questions that ask students to read and
interpret maps images audio and text
passages we have interactive charts and
graphs to teach students to read and
interpret data with a variety of
different question types consider
exploring our content to sample the
variety of practice questions we offer
our content gives instant feedback after
answering any questions students will
learn if they are correct or in
students who are stuck on a problem will
be provided with support such as related
videos and articles hints with solution
strategies and rationales that explain
why a particular answer is correct or
incorrect we've heard some teachers ask
if Khan Academy's content is student
friendly our content is definitely
student friendly and encourages a growth
mindset by letting students know that
they can learn anything we want students
to feel like they are receiving
personalized support we model thinking
processes that we hope students will use
as I ask questions and solve problems we
hope this video provides a look into the
content available on Khan Academy but we
know the best way to learn more is to
experience it choose a topic that
inspires you and explore it firsthand